boa tarde todo mundo escutando tudo
certo
bom gente você já parou para pensar que
a vida nem sempre é sorte mas sim
escolhas bom na minha vida nunca foi
questão de sorte por a gente por isso
que eu fiz que me trouxeram até aqui
eu me chamo o livina eu tenho 16 anos e
nasci em baião no interior do pará
bom desde pequena eu era muito ativa em
relação ao conhecimento
eu sempre queria conhecer sempre quis
ler e estudar
só que infelizmente as oportunidades que
me eram oferecidas eram suficientes
primeiro porque a escola não tinha
estrutura adequada e xu professor ainda
estimulados alunos não tinha muito
interesse e além disso tudo infelizmente
o paraíba está entre os estados com
apoio à educação do país segundo dados
ele possui a segunda maior taxa de
evasão em todas as etapas de ensino
inclusive no ensino médio e também ele
está entre os estados com pior idepi do
país
então devido a isso eu resolvi mudar
para a cidade de vocês cariocas
atão cidade maravilhosa
só que chegando aqui eu percebi que a
realidade não era tão maravilhosa assim
e vocês sabem disso a educação que eu
imaginava que eu buscava infelizmente é
igual ao do pará
só que um cenário maior e mesmo assim em
eu vim pra cá e comecei a estudar numa
escola pública a escola municipal
argentina em vila isabel na zona norte
onde mora atualmente
e foi um dos piores cenários pra mim
porque eu me senti muito estimulada
porque educação que eu queria que eu
imaginava não era que vivenciava mas
mesmo assim com apoio de casa eu
consegui finalizar o ano letivo em 2011
eu tive uma ideia para mudar a minha
realidade eu resolvi fazer um concurso
de bolsas ea minha mãe uma mulher que eu
admiro muito uma mulher forte e corajosa
também saiu do pará jovem pra buscar
melhores condições de vida para as duas
filhas que sou eu e meu irmão e para
buscar um futuro melhor
inscreveu no concurso de bolsas na
escola particular perto da minha casa
só que infelizmente não tinha estrutura
mas mesmo assim eu resolvi me inscrever
porque é a única opção que eu tinha de
melhorar então entre cinco candidatos e
10 vagas
eu passei dos primeiros lugares para
estudar nesta escola
só que infelizmente como já falei pra
vocês na minha vida nunca foi sorte
então no primeiro ano e os de nessa
escola a escola infelizmente fechou e eu
não podia voltar àquela realidade
vivenciada antes eu tinha que melhorar
eu não tinha opção
então por isso e motivada por isso eu
fiz outro concurso de bolsas uma escola
melhor só que por ser melhor
era muito mais concorrida então eu
resolvi escrever este concurso de bolsas
e entre 148 candidatos
eu passei em segundo lugar bom
é eu comecei pensando nessa escola e
chegando no período de férias eu eu
acredito que a gente dois tipos de
pessoas que se relacionam com o tempo as
pessoas que preferem ver o tempo passar
e pessoas como eu que aproveita o tempo
pois acreditam que o tempo que a gente
faz o que a gente vive no presente é
reflexo do futuro
então a minha irmã outra mulher
maravilhosa que eu tenho na minha vida
que atualmente é uma inspiração para mim
e que assim como pra mim ela também não
mede esforços para ajudar os outros me
escreveu uma série de cursos na puc onde
eu fiz vários cursos durante as férias
e ao finalizar o curso a professora
marina a diretora do projeto me chamou
na sala dela e disse que eu havia me
destacado entre os alunos e por isso ela
estava disposta a oferecer uma bolsa
para estudar audiovisual lá mesmo
durante um ano e além disso ela iria me
ofereceu uma bolsa para estudar inglês
durante seis anos na cultura inglesa que
onde estuda atualmente continua
estudando por um terceiro ano faltou
mais três que eu vou conseguir
bom só que a vida é cheia de altos e
baixos ea minha vida novamente teve um
baixo depois de quatro longos anos
estudando no colégio havia passado o
programa de bolsa da escola encerrou
e eu me vi numa situação desesperadora
porque eu senti que tudo aquilo que eu
tinha passado toda a minha vinda para cá
para o rio de janeiro o concurso de
bolsas que tinha feito tudo que eu tinha
alcançado foi em vão porque como o
projeto acabou o programa de bolsas
acabou eu teria que voltar às da escola
pública porque minha mãe não tinha
condições de pagar uma escola particular
pra mim
mas devido às pessoas que eu tinha na
minha vida e que eu tenho até hoje as
indicações
eu me inscrevi em outro concurso de
bolsas
uma das melhores escolas da zona sul do
rio de janeiro e entre 300 candidatos e
três vagas apenas eu passei em segundo
lugar
essa é uma história engraçada porque
quando eu fiz a prova
minha mãe ficou esperando oferece mãe
desistiu não passei ou teve gente que
foi muito pior que eu não passei então
sair já
esperançosa e quando ligaram para minha
casa e falaram que eu tinha passado eu
falei que o nomeou hoje já que lívia
outro nome mas era líbia mesmo eu passei
em segundo lugar no céu internet não
school onde estuda atualmente bom é mas
quando eu entrei no céu
eu comecei a trabalhar de verdade o meu
caminho eu comecei a descobrir de
verdade que eu queria fazer na minha
vida eu queria alcançar o objetivo que
ainda na faculdade era a maneira que eu
tinha de mudar minha realidade das
pessoas ao meu redor e por incrível que
pareça eu comecei a estudar muito mais a
me dedicar muito mais
e foi nesse período que eu vi que eu
tinha que fazer alguma coisa para mudar
a realidade de outras pessoas também
então novamente eu conversei com a minha
irmã
o sbt onde ocupará preciso fazer alguma
coisa tem 3g semana livre que eu estou
fazendo nada que eu vou fazer
então eu iniciei um trabalho voluntário
na creche santa inês naghavi que atende
mais de 250 crianças da rocinha e eu
fiquei durante um ano fazer um trabalho
voluntário lá
e essa foi uma das melhores experiências
da minha vida porque eu sempre amei
crianças
eu não entendi muito bem porque eu não
sei se foi por conta da vida da minha
mãe pra cá que eu fui eu não tive o
apoio dela mas não porque ela não quis
explicar precisava então eu sempre fui
muito apegada criança eu resolvi juntar
a minha vontade é a minha paixão por
criança
minha vontade por aprender e eu resolvi
fazer esse trabalho voluntário
fiquei um ano e onde trabalha atualmente
como jovem aprendiz na área
administrativa lá mas e hoje o que eu
quero hoje pra minha vida
primeiro quero concluir o curso de
inglês
logo depois de concluir eu quero fazer
um intercâmbio na califórnia
porque eu quero obviamente aumentar a
minha influência na língua eu quero
aprender novas culturas
eu quero abrir minha visão e as visões
de mundo
eu também quero passar direito isso é
uma decisão muito difícil porque o
talento de duas áreas muito parecidas
que é direito e medicina
mas esse ano eu decidi mesmo que eu
quero fazer direito porque é a forma que
eu quero transformar profissionalmente a
realidade das pessoas ao meu redor
hoje eu sou imensamente grata o todas as
pessoas que encaram na minha vida porque
são graças a ela é graças à minha mãe a
minha irmã
a minha avó está no pará hoje a todas as
pessoas que passaram pela minha vida a
puc a equipe do texas que estou muito
feliz de estar aqui hoje com vocês
principalmente a você alexandre muito
obrigada por todos os momentos porque
são graças a estas pessoas que eu
escolhi fazer direito porque eu preciso
eu tenho a obrigação o dever de
transformar a sociedade ao meu redor
eu quero através de direito igual
direitos civis principalmente entre os
negros e brancos
eu quero igualar a sociedade brasileira
porque eu não aceito que muitas pessoas
tenham muito e outras pessoas não tenham
nada hoje
o que importa pra mim de verdade é mudar
a realidade das pessoas estão
desacreditadas diariamente e mesmo sendo
desacreditadas
mesmo sendo injustiçados mesmo com as
voltas de jogo de oportunidades
elas continuam acreditando na esperança
diária
então na minha vida assim como a de
vocês escolhas foram feitas nunca foi e
nem será a questão de sorte
obrigada